hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner  sorry and calm and today we're going to  demonstrate how to do the two-point gate  using crutches so the two point we're  gonna have two points on the ground at a  time whether it's a crutch or a foot so  what does it look like well this is  where the patient will move the crutch  on the injured side so we're going to  say it's the right side so they move the  right crutch and they move the left foot  together then they will move the left  crutch on that non injured side and the  right foot together so you have two  points  thank you so much for watching and don't  forget to subscribe to our channel for  more videos